-Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
wedding fails from you guys.
This first one
is from @jwiederspan.
-Yeah.
-She says,
"Went to a wedding reception
a couple years ago,
and the DJ played only
karaoke versions of songs.
He sang the vocals
for every song."
[ Audience groans ]
-Oh. Oh-ho!
-Wow!
That is awful.
-Oh, my God.
-That is a nightmare.
"This song's a little bit
out of my range,
but I'm gonna try it anyway.
[ Off-key ]
♪♪ All by myself ♪♪
-Father and daughter dance
[ Laughter ]
I remember one time
at a wedding,
my friend Rob and Denise -
family friends.
We went to this wedding.
My mom always would
get in trouble at these
wherever we went.
She was just a magnet
for making trouble.
And she kind of had, like,
bad knees or something,
so she kind of, like, walked
like a little --
kind of like Ozzy Osbourne
[ Laughter ]
And so we went to this wedding
and what they're about to --
we're at the reception.
They're about to announce
the wedding party.
You know,
and then the bride and groom -
and Mom goes,
"I got to go to the bathroom."
I go, "Don't do it now.
Why would you do it now?
Wait till
they introduce everybody.
Just hold it for 10 minutes,
and then go."
She goes, "I got to go now."
I go, "All right.
Just do it quick before --
'Cause they haven't --
She goes, "Okay."
She's walking to the bathroom.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, and I'm like, "Oh, man
There's no way
she's gonna make it," you know
So, she's in there,
and me and my dad
are waiting for her
to come out and like --
And all of the sudden, the
start putting a smoke machine.
[ Laughter ]
So, this is a nightmare
for my mother.
This is like --
She's gonna come out of
the bathroom like,
"What happened?"
[ Laughter ]
So, smoke machine, laser beams
like, "All right, everybody.
Put your hands together.
We're gonna
get this party started!
Give it up for the bridesmaid!
Give it up for the best man!
And then they go,
"Here they are,
husband and wife,
Robert and Denise Daniel."
And my mom
comes walking through the fog.
[ Laughter ]
"What is --"
I'm like, "Gloria! Mom!
Get over here!
What are --"
[ Laughter ]
Unbelievable person.
-"The toilet broke."
[ Laughter ]
-She had no idea where she was
and what is happening.
Laser beams.
All right, this one
is from @yourbizsucks.
-Ooh, wow.
-Wow.
He says, "I was best man
at my friend's second wedding.
I started my speech with,
'Welcome back, everyone.'"
-Oh, snap.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-He was not happy.
-Oh.
Oh.
-I think that's funny.
-"Round two."
-[ Laughs ]
-"Three's the charm."
-This one is from
@Patrickneville.
He says, "I thought I was making
a calm, composed face
as my wife came down the aisle
I found out
this was the face I made."
Look at this photo.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oh, my God.
-Is she a ghost?
-Wow.
-This one's from @sdsmith987
She says, "My mother-in-la
brought platters of food
to my catered wedding receptio
so their side of the famil
would have something to ea
that they liked."
-Oh!
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
-Wow.
Strong move
on the mother-in-law.
-Wow.
"That they like."
Yeah.
"This is something we like."
-"We like to eat food we like.
I mean,
you can eat your garbage food.
-This one's from @lifealertme.
He says, "I danced so hard
I ripped my pants."
Look at the photo.
-Wow!
-Oh!
[ Applause ]
Wow!
I hope that --
I hope that's --
[ Laughter ]
That was underwear we saw.
-Oh, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @beerstat.
He says,
"I went to a wedding at a farm
The ceremony was completel
drowned out by the sounds
of a cow giving birth
in a nearby shed."
[ Laughter ]
Well, the beauty of nature
[ Both imitating
cow mooing loudly ]
-"Do you take --"
-[ Mooing loudly ]
-"Oh, God!"
"Push, Bessie, push!"
[ Laughter ]
-"Push, Bessie."
Oh, my God.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Mooing ]
-"Thanks goodness we took her --
we did those lamaze classes.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-This one's from @acampisi
She says,
"All three of the grandmothers
unexpectedly showed up
to the wedding
in the exact same dress."
Look at this.
-Oh!
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I love the claps in there
-Yeah.
[ Clapping ]
-In the exact same dress.
[ Laughter ]
That's pretty classic.
This one's called
@Iamishishone.
She says, "I went
to a beach wedding in Florida.
A seagull flew by,
and dropped a fish head
on the mother of the bride."
[ Audience groans ]
-Ugh.
-Nothing like a fish head.
-A fish head.
-Oh, my God.
This one is classic.
This one's from @Amypennza
She says, "My mother-in-law wore
a wedding dress to my wedding.
So, yeah.
Top that one, Twitter."
Look at this.
She wore a wedding dress!
-Oh!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Come on!
-You can't do that!
-That is unbelievable!
There you have it.
Those are our
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags